[Music]
[Applause]
by the power of crowder shop
i have the powers
dave you're not wearing pants tis true
where'd dave get those cool threads
wouldn't you like to know
it's a mystery but you can start your
treasure hunt at crowdershop.com
i think you'll be pleasantly surprised
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
moist in the palate that uh i just
realized that is stale oh yeah it is uh
tuesday morning which for most people
means uneventful
wednesday's hump day monday is a
horrible day
tuesday doesn't feel like anything but
i'll tell you what it feels like today
uh
saying hello to an old friend who we
have not seen now full disclosure i've
spoken of course with uh our next guest
uh behind the scenes but a lot of you
have been asking why hasn't he been here
on the show um well look we'll talk
about that with them usually we've been
doing guest segments i think this one
warrants
long-form sit-down because well first
off you're not going to get them to
answer a question in anything then
you know a novella
uh but a very fought out though very
smart man uh we actually i think this
was the first show to really have him
sort of stateside because uh originally
we wrote about him at a lot of
crowder.com with the free speech laws
from my
homeland of canada and this guy
really was look i think some people may
not appreciate and i don't wanna you
know i don't i don't want to uh do this
with him here because he'll he'll get
embarrassed but the truth is
uh
this man took a big risk and i want
people to really appreciate
what he the limb he stepped out on uh
the reason you know who he is
right now is not because of joe rogan
and not because of the show but he was a
public enemy in canada free speech
doesn't exist in canada and so now he's
talked about a lot of other things and
he's he's brilliant he's a professor but
the whole reason he came to the
forefront is because he was one of the
few people in academia in a country
where you are not allowed to go against
groupthink
and he took a stand at great risk to
himself and so i think that lawrence as
his first time back here um doing a long
form interview time about everything the
whole world is different so i'm curious
to see what he has to say what's going
on right now in
in his world because we haven't spoken
since the pandemic yeah this is a
totally different
interview whole new world a whole new
man whole new world uh let's get to it
with
dr jordan peterson
[Music]
all right uh here he is who's talking
about i mean i can give him an
introduction yeah but
uh you know does he need does he need
one i mean i can say doctor because
he'll make a whole big thing about it
but uh i don't know if he's been on
since this new book has been out but you
could say professor but it's three
syllables well you know listen you're
asking a lot of me sir what with the
sinus infection and the the soft palate
effect there and uh the new book is
beyond order 12 more rules for life so a
lot of rules uh you follow him on the
twitter jordan b peterson uh
professor thank you for being here sir
how are you
i'm i'm i'm quite well at the moment
actually um
i'm
i'm so happy about that i can't believe
it so that's that's good i'm talking to
you and
and i'm looking forward to it oh you
know i'm well if that's the case i was
going to say yeah i don't know you must
have had to to to rally for this um so
let me do my very best to shoot that
down do you think you're feeling so well
because of all your wouldn't be because
of all your rules now would it professor
oh you can't have too many rules man so
24 is just that's just the tip of the
iceberg isn't that kind of funny though
that you
and i would say myself a lot of people
um who sort of had had run-ins with big
tech you're sort of seen as an anti
certainly an anti-authoritarian figure i
just have a general problem with
authority
full stop but then you really are a big
believer in rules in order um is that
more so personal rules and boundaries as
opposed to something being enforced
externally do you think that's a big
difference
yeah well i'm not interested so much in
what people should and shouldn't do
in in some rural sense
i'm more interested in trying to
discover and discuss with people
what principles
we should live by
each of us as individuals that would
serve
each of us and the collective best and i
can't see why
why you wouldn't want that i mean if
you're bitter and cynical and resentful
and you want things to go to hell
and i you know i can understand that and
i understand how people get there but
i i'm not really interested in stopping
people from misbehaving because what
they're doing is wrong is
that i'm interested in investigating
what are the principles that
that help you live a life that
that justifies itself and even more than
that you know if you're fortunate and so
and maybe it's because i'm not finger
wagging in some sense that people are
willing to put up with the fact that i'm
writing about rules and they're for me
too right they're not i'm not saying
these are for other people and i'm also
not saying that i can abide by them all
the time
so i no there's no way to i mean that's
the only person who who can abide by all
the rules that are said is is jesus and
that was kind of the great irony of it
it's like yeah you guys can't do this
only i can and then anyone else coming
around but let me ask you this this is
something and this might be a bit of a
smart ass question but um so you wrote
the first book and there's 12 rules
what point did you go
and you realized that you missed 12.
oh well ha i do have an answer for that
okay that isn't what happened i wrote 43
rules oh all right okay so this is and
exactly that's right i haven't thrust
all my rules upon anyone yet so well i i
wrote i wrote an answer to a question on
quora i wrote like 50 answers i had a
quora fit there for a while and and
wrote a bunch of answers and and some
kid had written in saying you know
what what principles help you live a
meaningful life let's say right so i
cranked out 43 rules just very fast you
know and then
that
answer became very popular on quora it's
way more popular than any of my other
answers and so then i talked to my first
agent uh sally harding
and
about a more popular book i wrote this
book called maps of meaning which is
sure hard book and um
though the audio version is probably
more accessible and we were talking
about how some of these ideas might be
made more publicly accessible and i
remembered this list of rules and the
fact that it was popular and i thought
well you know it's been market tested
already and i don't mean that in a
cynical way
you know i mean i look if you're going
to write a book
a popular book you want people to read
it otherwise you're a fool
and
if you don't pay attention to what
people are interested in then you're not
meeting your audience halfway
right and
that's how it came about and so i picked
12 that i kind of thought went together
thematically and that struck me as as
interesting and meaningful and i wrote
the first book and then well i did the
same and then they i grouped them
yeah well i think that one was an
antidote to chaos and one was
was a danger about the danger of to or a
warning about the danger of too much
order so that kind of covers the
political landscape in some sense yeah
definitely i wonder to you just touched
on something that's why you have more um
you know there's some people like
yourself who have more staying power um
and that's because like you said you're
not you are meeting your audience
halfway but then on the flip side of
people who are just sort of who who are
what i would consider trend chasers
right they throw bombs they look at the
trend they throw something in there some
red meat get people riled up
but then once that trend goes away they
go away and we've always said look if
we're talking about subjects that don't
interest people or don't matter to
people on this show we're not really
serving our audience but perfect example
might be last week you know the fbi uh
they were having to deal with the sex
scandal of the olympic gymnasts and not
reporting this for 17 months and 40 more
women having come forward being raped
you know and uh i use that to segue into
something that i've wanted to talk about
regarding the difference between field
agents and corruption in our
intelligence agencies for a long time
but there just wasn't really an in and
how are you going to get people to go
long history of fbi and cia corruption
and i'm not talking about insane false
flag operations i'm talking about things
that have been determined in a court of
law where people have already been tried
and convicted that most people don't
know about but we said this is a perfect
opportunity because now eyes are on the
fbi's transgressions and kind of you
know you feather it into what matters to
people so that you buy yourself some
leeway so that you can say well
may i offer this up perhaps this might
be of interest
and i noticed that you you do that and i
think it's an important delineation
between what people like you do and
certainly what i try and do versus
someone who's just you know
trump 2024
well i'm trying constantly to talk about
things that i think are
are true in some sense regardless of
time and place i mean i'm not trying to
make some claim that i've managed that
but
look the 12 rules for life the first
book
it hit the number 10 spot on the london
times bestseller list again this week
it's four years later
and so it's been perennially in the top
10 on amazon and
the reason for that i think is that
i didn't bind it to anything
specifically political that was topical
at that moment and i didn't want to do
that and and i'm trying not to do that
with my podcast as well and
and in terms of meeting the audience
halfway i mean i really try to do that
in my lectures too
when i go on tour when i went on tour
and
i don't use notes and part of the reason
for that is that i'm looking at audience
members all the time i'm i always pick
someone out and talk to them and then i
pick someone else out and
i'm talking to to that person i'm not
lecturing
i'm not lecturing and and i'm meeting
the i'm meeting people
you meet the whole audience if you
concentrate on one person and and that's
much well that's working and
yeah it's a good it's a good thing to do
it's a dialogue that way because you get
you get the audience then informs you as
well right right so and so you feel like
you get inspiration from you you know
it's funny i don't i don't definitely i
don't use notes just because i i can't
write them i'm dyslexic so it reads suns
let's see this is just a penis i don't
know if we can see that's all i did on
here there's nothing useful um it's not
a very good one
well it's it's it's uh it's a
self-portrait thank you uh professor um
lots of people would agree with that
yeah well look no not the least of all
my wife
even um hey speaking of things that you
like and meeting people we were just
talking about this uh not long ago one
of your guilty pleasures i hope i'm not
outing you i think people will be
thrilled to hear this
it shouldn't be a surprise because
you're canadian and i know you to have a
sense of humor but sometimes you know
people see you as more of a father
figure uh i'm just gonna come up trailer
park boys you've seen every episode
right
oh i've seen every episode a number of
times yes okay yeah i i find that i
it's i grew up in a working-class
community in canada in the north i mean
that's all atlantic canada humor the
trailer park boys but it's the same
thing and
uh yeah i i think those three characters
are comic geniuses i really do i mean
it's filthy and it's it's it's it's
obscene and it's way too much
yeah it's inexcusable it's way too much
and it reminds me of fubar which is
another it's a canadian movie and it's
about the same sort of people except in
the west and it's even more deadly aimed
at the sort of people that i grew up
with and they were working class people
and they they were smart and they were
bonded to each other and they were witty
and and
well i'm trying to rationalize this i
think it's funny i think they're funny
yeah the honky episode when they when
when the bubbles character the
ventriloquist
damn puppet i mean i think that's one of
the funniest 30 minutes of television
that's ever been produced it's really
work of g of terrible awful unforgivable
obscene genius and so more power to them
and yeah i'm big fans yeah
was that work i haven't seen that i
haven't seen that news he's like
something's [ __ ] cranky he's trying
to tell me to kill julian that kind of
thing yeah yeah that's that's exactly it
pretty good imitation too that was uh
you know what that was actually and i
maybe perhaps i was reading into it too
much i thought that was a send-up of uh
i don't remember anthony hopkins of film
magic where he was sort of a serial
killer through a ventriloquist dummy uh
and maybe they hadn't made that
connection but every time you know
someone is sort of a cinephile and i've
i've seen the only other person who i
know who's seen more is dave who's who's
not here right now i always go wait
maybe there's a connection there and you
know what i might want to tell you maybe
let me turn you on to a show it's not a
canadian show but it's you will see you
can just hear the canadian accent
it's all shot in vancouver even though
it's set in seattle it's called louder
milk and it's about a 12-step program
ron livingston uh heads up a 12-step
sort of alcoholics anonymous program um
in seattle he's a former music critic
and i don't want to give it away but i
will say brian regan who's just no not
only as a comedian but an ultra clean
kind of goofy dad-like comedian but
really well respected deserves an emmy
he will rip your heart out
louder milk louder milk yeah there's
three seasons and i hope to god they
make a fourth but it is a really really
good show and there is definitely a
canadian bent there just because you
know it absorbs it's it's a character in
and of itself even though it's set in
seattle we all know what it's like out
there in western canada i kind of only
have heard tales because i grew up in
quebec where we're not really witty and
bonded they're mostly just loud holes
they speak french too which is really
unforgivable it really is in this day
and age it's like get on get get on
board guys it's like you know
i should join the rest of the world oh
it absolutely it absolutely see i'm not
even joking though when i say that um i
people used to get furious when i would
point to quebec as an example of
multiculturalism versus the melting pot
in the united states gone wrong and i
would talk to americans when i lived in
new york and i would say do you realize
you can just go 30 minutes north to the
border and you can go into a country
with it with its own culture different
language they don't speak a word of your
language you can't read a word of your
language they don't watch the same shows
they don't know your same celebrities
and they are a part of an english
country known as canada but you will
have gone to quebec and you won't know
that it's canada and by the way they
have a nationally representative party
whose only interest is to separate from
canada i said this is part of the
political and these were conquered
people who the english said you know
what all right we'll let you have this
and we go through the planes of abraham
and i tell americans to go you just
don't know that's why you say okay look
french french folk time for you to to
feather in
canada's english and and then you have
the referendums to it'd be like it'd be
like texas separating because they
wanted to just be spanish it doesn't
make any sense americans aren't
understanding this but quebec sicily
place that's my point
i should say in quebec's defense let's
say that montreal is a great city and
that's true if if people in the u.s want
a quick taste of europe
montreal is a great place it's one of
the world's great it's truly one of the
world's great cities it really is i love
montreal i lived there for like eight
years and it uh it's such a great city
it's so fun it's got such a dynamic
culture the street life is amazing it's
really really safe like you could wander
around anywhere at three in the morning
it's no problem it's beautiful well i
can't i was mugged twice
in montreal yeah i was mugged over a set
of interpol tickets by a small haitian
incidental i only say it because the
story was one that i've told on air yeah
it uh i was bugged for interpol tickets
uh he was a scalper anyway mugged me for
the money for the interpol tickets and
then anyway the whole point that's
really humiliating that's really i'm
that's
especially because he was small and it
was montreal it's like how did you
manage that and twice do you know how he
got away
he screamed i swear to you this is true
he screamed out that i was racist and i
and i stopped
chasing him
that's good that should have happened to
you that absolutely absolutely should
have happened this is this is the true
story okay i'm going to see god up in
the clouds
because i was going why isn't anyone
stopping him i was going to see interpol
that night with my friend carl it was a
band sort of an indie rock band i was
going to see them at i believe was
metropolis or spectrum and uh i was
going to what i knew was a scalper
and he didn't have inner pole tickets
but another guy who
you know he presented himself as a
scalper turns out not all i don't know
if you know this you have to be uh
choosy with your scalpers they're not
all i mean not all scalpers are honest
not all legitimate uh is that something
though ironically you'll hear at the end
of this tale it was all redeemed through
it through an honest scalper so this
small uh haitian man says oh you want
interpol tickets i'm not going to try
and do his accent because people get all
mad but rest assured he had one uh
sounds like most people who are haitian
immigrants in montreal and he said i got
interpol tickets and i said okay he gave
me the price and i said it seems a
little steep but okay so he goes to i
can't remember which hotel i just
remember it wasn't the queen elizabeth
it wasn't a hotel i was familiar with it
but i gotta go pick them up at the front
desk right away i'm thinking this is
weird he just said he has interpol
tickets why would he go to this hotel
front desk so he goes there and then he
goes into the restroom
again should have given me a red flag
i'm 16 years old mind you uh
okay well that's a bit more yeah yeah 16
years old and he comes out
and then he has uh i see him putting
stuffing with like toilet paper in this
envelope and he goes all right here the
tickets give me the money and i said
no that's not those aren't tickets
he said what do you mean i said those
are toilet paper there's toilet paper
envelopes and he goes how do you how do
you know that i said well i saw you put
toilet paper in there and he goes like
man he he walks out so okay he walks up
the revolving door and then when i walk
i was waiting for me he's like no no you
you missed you mistook it this is these
are the tickets and he shows what
actually looks like tickets at this
point i said oh okay so then i hold my
money but i see that he's covering up
the name and the ticket and i said let
me see the ticket he goes whoa what you
don't trust me you don't trust me he
starts making these accusations and i
said no no just show me the ticket he
grabs the money from my hand
but the good thing is he he ripped the
20 bills in half so it was of no value
to him so i find solace in that then he
runs out in the middle of the street and
went hey hey that guy guys guys took my
money and i'm at this point six foot one
six foot two but very skinny but this
guy could is all of five foot three
and he's running through the street and
i go why isn't anyone doing it of course
no french hey film that guy that battle
mac they're not friendly at all and this
guy just goes what you're saying it
because i'm black you're racist and i
stopped him like what no no and he just
ran into an alleyway
and i thought well now the alleyway has
him now i'm 16 and it's an alleyway and
then finally i told the story to another
scalper who was right outside the
interpol concert at that point the show
had already started he said man there
are some really dis uh there's some
really rough people out there here and
he he gave me the tickets because they
were of no worth uh at that point the
show had already started he gave me
interpol tickets which was very nice but
then he said don't trust the haitians
and i said you're racist that's the pro
that so it could have been full the
devil scalper and the saint scalper the
same night right yeah so the point is
not as safe as you make it out to be but
yes montreal is a wonderful city uh to
to visit i don't know that i would ever
want to live there again with the taxes
and i don't know that i could raise kids
there at this point
i mean i loved living there i loved
living there so our times square is club
super sex in montreal when i tell people
that i go our santa claus parade is
going back giant flashing neon purple
tits it's not like there's a red light
district it's the whole city and
americans like your exaggerator just go
visit but unbelievable restaurants uh a
lot of fun um so trailer park boys okay
this is this is something that might
surprise quite a few people a lot has
changed since we last spoke i know i
wanted to talk with you about this
because i know you're you're eating some
jerky right now right am i seeing that
lamb
yeah yes okay
it's beef with lamb fat well i know
you've talked about you know sort of the
carnivore diet i accidentally went on
the carnivore diet after my surgery
recently
for like hard line accidentally nothing
but red meat for about five weeks
accident what happened uh well i had
surgery and then uh i i gained
30 pounds in a week and a half now i
didn't know at that time that it was uh
i had a gallon and a half of fluid in my
well for con for the canadians out there
five and a half liters of fluid in my
thoracic cavity so i said oh i'm getting
i'm really gaining weight i mean i
looked like i was you know looked like
macaulay culkin after he found out it
was allergic to bees and my girl and i
uh i i said i should cut out sweets
well that didn't do anything i still
kept gaining weight because you know i
didn't know what's going on internal
bleeding and such i said well you know
now i'll just cut out carbs and it
didn't work but at that point once i had
been drained uh you know surgically i
had already gotten into that rhythm and
i was kind of by myself after five days
in the scu to recover and i kind of
enjoy grilling it's something i've
always done you know my wife will make
the sides if we do a grill night and
then i'll make the meat but at this
point my wife was across the country
preparing to have twins because we
didn't foresee these complications so
i'm recovering by myself and i'm growing
like a porterhouse and saying i don't i
don't want to learn how to make the
sides that's my wife's thing
so it was born out of laziness you are a
sexist you're a sexual and lazy too yes
and you're and you're a carnivore you're
carnivorous you're really a bad person i
am an awful human being sounds like it
yes yes did you lose weight when you
started eating just meat or was that
still like were you still being affected
by the surgical no so so i lost i lost
uh like the 30 pounds in about six days
because they actually drink weight so i
went in about 2 30 and i came out about
2 32
so yeah but it was i tell you what i
didn't feel bad uh i was surprised that
it was just sort of born out of all
right at this point i was i was doing
one meal a day and i've just always
preferred red meat
i'm not saying that i'm i'm a doctor i
would advocate it necessarily anyone but
it was accidental and it was it was a
fun little experiment nothing in other
words there was no there were no side
effects there was no you know sometimes
you were like oh i go through this when
it's like i think it could be a blood
type thing because when i was a kid my
mom used to call me a carnivore i go to
mcdonald's and i'd say could i not get
the fries just double up on the burger
patties and she'd lock me in a closet
well that accounts for that accounts for
some of your weird personal
characteristics i guess
yeah well i've been eating i've been
eating basically nothing but meat i
don't like to talk about this much
because i'm not a dietitian and it's
really weird in some ways i just hate
this diet because i love to cook and i
love to go out to restaurants it's very
restrictive but
i when i went on this diet to begin with
because of autoimmune issues as far as i
could tell yeah i lost like 50 pounds in
six months it was ridiculous like i
wasn't
really that much overweight i'm about
six two so
but it like eight pounds a month it was
unbelievable i just couldn't believe it
and that is permanent i've never gained
the weight back and so now i'm down to
the same weight i was when i was like 26
and
um
even back that was in 2015 i was up to
about 2 12 and i'm at 165 now um
you know i wasn't i wasn't in great
shape
but
but i was tall enough to carry it but
losing that much weight was quite the it
was a real shock to me a conceptual
shock i couldn't believe it i still
can't believe it for me it was different
gaining the weight so quickly i mean i
think this is something people realize
psychologically and i would imagine it
happens to a varying degree but long
term you know right now we've sort of
talked i've talked about this on the
show to kind of go back to something a
little a little more philosophical the
fat pride
movement for example and this sort of
ties in obviously with as we're
struggling with an international
pandemic and the single thing is
preventative you know co-morbidity is is
obesity but we're not allowed to talk
about it because we've declared that
it's beautiful um
you know when i gained that much weight
very quickly i felt it on my joints now
keep in mind this was obviously fluid in
my thoracic cavity was basically you
know medically induced it was a
complication but i felt like a very
different person and it was amazing how
much it also affected my psyche and i've
got to imagine that even if that's
happening over the course of a long
period of time sure physiologically you
adjust more you know the connective
tissue but it's got to have an effect on
your mental state and like you've talked
about even losing the weight
and right now this is this is right
have we bound ourselves in such a knot
to kind of go here with to me covid and
the fat price and we need to delineate
people who are overweight and want to
lose weight and that's an entirely
different situation than someone saying
you will declare me beautiful and
healthy um
at the same
time well one of the things i've already
been thinking about lately and i'm going
to write the next book that i'm going to
write
about this i think
at least in part is that
it seems to me that if we don't have a
delineated
space conceptually and socially for the
sacred and the religious and that it's
put in its proper relationship to the
other things that we're concerned about
then what happens is not that we become
pure rationalists as people like dawkins
and and harris for example might hope
but that
much that should never be religious
instantly becomes contaminated with it
right and so an issue like
like body size
relative obesity starts to take on this
intensely moral
uh uh element
and and the people who are
pushing hard against
shaming someone if they're fat they have
their point but
it should be it shouldn't be a moral
issue to begin with if you're overweight
it's not because you're a bad person
there's all sorts of reasons that you
might be overweight and we should be
able to have a discussion about that
without it becoming moral and we can't
and part of the reason for that is well
we don't know what's sacred and what
isn't and and we don't even know that
some things have to be and we certainly
don't know what things should be and so
everything in our political landscape is
becoming contaminated as far as i can
tell with
what are essentially religious concerns
and and i mean that psychologically not
theologically yeah so and that's not
good it's it's it's very bad it also
means that we're going to be more more
tempted to elevate our leaders our
political leaders
into spaces of of treatment that should
be reserved for the sacred and and
that's not a good thing either i mean
politicians are basically administrators
in in that's the proper sense that's the
proper conception
right so yeah as opposed to to leaders
are really almost almost executive
decision makers that's not necessarily
what they're supposed to be empowered to
do well they're not kings no they're not
kings i mean one of the weaknesses i
think of the american political system
which i admire greatly is that
it's not a monarchy it's not a
constitutional monarchy and i think the
advantage to a constitutional monarchy
is that
you have someone carry the weight of the
symbol symbolism of the state
and so because you see this and you
really see this in the u.s and do you
see it manifest itself in celebrity
culture too it's very hard for
americans not to turn the president and
his family into something like the royal
family and
americans place a tremendous amount of
attention on
the first family it's very foreign to
canadians because we never do that in
canada for for one reason or another but
you know your president has to carry all
that symbolic weight and that's
that's not good i think i think it's a
problem it's a stark contrast you know
we have assassination attempts in canada
they have success
successful pieings of the prime minister
well they will get pied in the face and
that has happened
many times now i tell americans that
they go wait you mean like your pres i
go yes like our president they go like a
like what like a like a boston cream pie
right in the face on a podium on
national television it has happened
multiple times they go you can't be
serious i say yes i am uh and uh i i had
someone on this show essentially that
you bring up sort of discussing the
monarchy i don't remember who it was and
i i'm so pleased if this person
remembers i don't want to miss giving
them credit or maybe they were quoting a
philosopher said you know the one thing
that people sort of fail to realize
about the monarchy is
unlike a pure democracy at least in the
sense with the monarchy or royal family
they had some kind of
attachment to
to their legacy and wanting to be
remembered fondly wanting to be
remembered well because really there
wouldn't be this capability of passing
the buck that you voted for this this is
a democracy so some in some ways they
were actually um
more beholden to some kind of at least
self-governing uh moral uh moral compass
moral guidance code of ethics he said
that's one of the sort of the great
attributes uh that people often
miss out on i thought very uh very uh
introspectively on the monarchy the
worst part uh the fruity hats
you don't you're not a fan of the hats
not a fan of the hats
yeah but i'm just the first part was
true the second part that was just my
editorializing but it is interesting
though too i mean it is true it's given
to us a king this is as old as time i
mean this is this is really one of the
original sins of of the bible and one
thing going back to what you're talking
about sort of not keeping our sacred
institutions separate i see a lot when i
grew up not even noticing that we
actually need a space for the sacred and
and we need to figure out what that is
and it isn't optional and this is one of
the problems i have with the atheist
rationalist types is that and the
mistake they're making i believe is that
they treat religion as if it's a set of
propositions about the nature of reality
like a scientific theory and and
religious people make a huge mistake
because they react to the scientific
criticisms also as if that's the case
but the religious is this has nothing to
do with an argument for against the
existence of god by the way that's
that's a separate issue right
it's that
the religious covers all sorts of
of elements of experience that aren't
propositionalized they're not statements
about the structure of reality so
architecture
has a religious element you certainly
see that in the cathedrals music
ritual
yeah
all of that
that it's more in that it's more in the
domain of the arts let's say so that
that's technically speaking so but then
also within the domain of human
experience so
we all have the capacity to experience
awe
for example and we can experience that
to a greater or lesser degree and i
would say
the more profound the experience of awe
the more it shades into what's always
been described in religious terms and so
you can say well we'll dispense with
religion but well what about the
experience of awe that's not a
proposition it's not an argument it's
something that happens to you and it
takes you unaware right you don't
necessarily expect it to happen although
sometimes you'll seek it out and you
experience all when you're in the face
and it seems to me that this is the case
you experience awe when you're faced by
something that calls you it's beyond you
it's greater than you so you see that
and you experience that but then it also
calls to you in some sense to be better
than you are
right and that seems to be an intrinsic
part of the experience and so and
there's no just rationally dispensing
with that and atheist or not
you can experience this i think you
experience it when you look up at the
night sky if you're somewhere
extraordinarily dark and and maybe that
it's a problem that modern people often
don't have that experience now and so
so and and
so so the argument i'm formulating i
suppose like i said this is part of the
next book i'm planning to write is that
we need to have a really serious
conversation about
this the psychological reality of the
religious and how it exists in
relationship to let's say the political
or the ideological because if that's all
mangled together in cautiously all sorts
of things happen
that we don't want to have happened and
that's the issue of rendering unto god
what is god and unto caesar what is
caesar's and that's also
the idea that church and state need to
be separated not only politically and
and constitutionally say but also
conceptually yeah otherwise we get
muddied up and so what are the atheists
the atheist types what they don't what
they haven't grappled with as far as i
can tell is well
there is a hierarchy of values some
values are lesser than others
otherwise you wouldn't be able to pursue
what you believe to be the most
important so some things announce
themselves as more important than other
things there's a ranking of those
the most important issues they're in the
domain of something approximating the
religious and whenever you touch on them
you elicit from people religious
experience religious reactions
and and like i said that has nothing to
do with an argument for against the
existence of god it's a philosophical
and conceptual issue and part of the
problem that we're facing in our society
is that we're we're muddying the lines
and that means all sorts of things get
inflated beyond their
uh
their necessary importance and it also
means that the arguments aren't about
what we're arguing about at all they're
about something underneath that's hidden
yeah and that pops up everywhere i think
no more apparent than actually to sort
of piggyback on that but explain a
little bit of a difference in where i
was raised and i was on youtube in 2006
right and then 2009 doing every week and
there were no conservatives there were
no real christians that no one of
significant note not like today like
yourself or other even christian and
political channels out there uh uh
self-help to whatever we wanted however
we want to describe them it was the edgy
atheist territory right it was you were
an atheist or bust and i watched them
sort of always try and attack christians
and i wouldn't say um
in a way that's completely unfounded
with well how do you reconcile your
religion
in the face of this scientific data you
know that's what they would often be
arguing the evolution argument was very
big back then whereas now i see it on
the flip side where especially in this
sort of era of covid where like you're
talking about in muddying the lines
sometimes science has tried to insert
itself and almost replace religion and
people not necessarily science itself
but people have tried to turn to science
as a religion for for example things
that are unexplainable sometimes um well
the other the other problem that comes
up there as far as i can tell and sam
harris has tried to address this
although i don't think he's done it
successfully
is that
you're always we're always faced with
the problem of perception and action we
have to see the world we have to hear
the world we have to interact with the
world through our senses and we have to
act
none of that's
optional
and even to perceive something you have
to
select what's important and what isn't
so if you listen to someone in a crowded
room you focus in on their speech and
not on the speech of the people in the
background right and so you you
prioritize that person's speech in the
hierarchy of value that guides your
perception
well
so you're stuck with
existing inside a system of value
there's no way out of that
well
it isn't obvious at all that science
can provide us with guides as to what
constitutes the appropriate values and
it's not obvious to scientists in fact i
would say that science in some sense was
designed so that that was something it
didn't even try to do right because it's
trying to present an objective viewpoint
devoid of to the degree that it's
possible devoid of a prior value
judgments but then you have this whole
domain of well we need to make judgments
of value well okay
where do they come from and and and when
i point out for example that there are
things that call to you experientially
that are outside of rationality i would
say to the atheists well why don't you
look at the science of religious
experience let's say or or that domain
and try to account for that from within
your particular perspective if you
criticize the religious people for not
following the science it's a lot of what
are you going to do with this fact that
human beings
are
wired for example
to admire and to imitate that which they
uh which they find calls them to a
greater self right that's the the
instinct for imitation and so what is it
we're imitating and and why do we
imitate that particular value
and so
that the whole that
well that's a domain of unexplored
mystery that has to be taken seriously
this isn't a matter of mere rationality
by no means and i think you make a great
point about the the hierarchy of values
and so you end up looking toward a
messianic figure i mean this is this is
kind of what's what was supposed to be
beautiful to me about the scientific
process i hate the word the science now
the science is the equivalent to uh it
isn't equivalent to religion just like
scientology a certain way they put
science in the name the science
especially if someone says that with a
fouchy pillow in their office which
governor whitmer did of my wonderful
home state of michigan um science what
was beautiful about it is that it wasn't
determined by consensus like you said
that that was by design it was
determined by truth it didn't
necessitate as a matter of fact it
rejected people saying this is the right
science because of consensus no no if
the consensus is the world is flat but
it's wrong the science says that you're
wrong and now we're at this point where
um
people are don't even understand they're
making these same religious judgments
and saying when we say trust the science
we're saying fauci well on a second what
about when fauci goes against the world
health organization what about when the
world health organization doesn't
actually correspond with the cdc what
about the fact that you have other
scientists at the time for example
who've come out and said fauci was wrong
while he was talking about the fact that
if you lived in a home with a parent who
had aids you could catch it from a
cereal box this is all on the record you
had all kinds of other scientists who
were more qualified who said this is not
the guy and people and not understanding
that they've made this value judgment
have said no no i've decided he's the
guy and this is a real problem right now
because
you know this this kind of brings me and
i i hope that this all makes sense and
you can just tell me if i'm if i'm
stammering i've always said my litmus
test for a conspiracy theory when you
have to kind of dismiss it right you
can't go through every conspiracy that
someone brings up you have to debunk
you'd have too much
too much to debunk you do have to start
with how many people is they how many
people is they in this conspiracy theory
how many people yeah okay so so okay so
one of the things you're suggesting
implicitly is that one of the ways we
establish value judgments is through
consensus but that isn't how we do
science
and fair enough but but it does point to
some mechanism for the establishment of
value so if you're trying to figure out
what's important what isn't well one way
you can do that is to see what people in
general think and that might be a
reasonable thing to do but as you
pointed out that's not part of the
scientific process certainly not it'd be
very weak if it was right and now i
guess my point that i was going to sort
of in where we live the domain you know
big big tech this sort of sphere where
we
at one point were really grateful that
there weren't gatekeepers the conspiracy
now when we say hold on a second we're
talking about fouchy the cdc and
scientific guidelines that fly in the
face of other scientific guidelines the
they and this conspiracy is really only
about
five heads of organizations
people have decided about five you're
talking about five companies
in about two or three international
governing bodies who determine what is
allowed to be spoken regardless of your
scientific qualifications
for it to be considered proper or
misinformation and by the way they can
change that a week from now and they
have we've documented at least 20
something times
that to me
so it's really talking i talked to i
talked to john anderson
last week he's the debt was the deputy
prime minister of australia a variety of
years ago a number of years right he uh
was finance minister when they ran
something like five consecutive budget
surpluses nationally
that's a hell of an accomplishment for a
western democracy man so he's a very
sensible guy
and we were talking about what was
happening in australia underneath this
this
as a consequence of the covid pandemic
and and various other
uh causes
and his point essentially too was that
well because politicians in some sense
are abdicating their responsibility
we're forcing medical people to make
what are essentially political decisions
and so
just as much of the dialogue that much
of the problems that be said as
politically are a consequence of the
bleeding over of religious concerns into
the political domain we now have
bleeding over of the scientific concerns
into the political domain because
politicians are using these experts as
proxies for their own particular uh for
pushing forward their own particular
ideological positions and that's a very
dangerous misuse of science and so you
see that in the climate change
discussion too where
the insistence is well here's the
problem and this is the magnitude of the
problem and it's a moral issue and you
have to accept that or you're not a good
person or you're ignorant or you're
malevolent
you're a bad person fundamentally but
the part of the reason that that
insistence is there is because there's a
pack of solutions at hand in that
person's imagination that are usually
ideological in nature and if the first
proposition is true then
that the the imposition of that
particular set of solutions is a fait
accompli
and so not examining that is
extraordinarily dangerous because
you're
if you have that ideological set of
solutions then you're going to be
extraordinarily tempted
to
co-opt the force of the scientific
endeavor as a justification for your
political ambitions it's very difficult
for people to separate those sorts of
things out like i believe personally i i
believe this
is that
it's very very probable to me that
massive
solutions to the climate change problem
like global scale solutions even
national scale solutions are going to
cause far more trouble than the problem
itself will cause i really believe that
of course so yeah no i don't think
there's any question about that i mean i
learned that again when i was 20 years
old and i went to the cancun climate
summit and i watched ted turner proposed
china's one child policy to thunderous
applause everyone had flown into cancun
they hadn't heard
i was there
i was there and i said oh you know what
for me that's when i stopped
trying to feign being a centrist i said
oh no why did that why why did that
strike you so hard do you think how old
were you and so why did that hit you so
hard might have been i would have been
21 or 22 i just started it at fox news i
think it struck me so hard because it
was sort of funny you know
you always see the hypocrisy uh
everyone's a hypocrite i always say
don't focus on the hypocrisy focus on
the the whether it's genuine for example
nancy pelosi was a hypocrite when she
went and had her air vortex blown out
it's not that she's a hypocrite it's
that she doesn't believe about covid
what she tells her constituents or she
wouldn't be going out in public and
putting her head into a particle
accelerator um so the issue there is i
had seen the hypocrisy it was kind of
funny they all really were all a bunch
of climate scientists
finding an excuse to vacation in cancun
this is when it was still a kodo
protocol and then it hit me
when
about as bad of a policy as you can
think of right almost a policy that
would be considered a straw man if you
were to say to an environmental almost
paganist which is a pagan which is what
i would determine some of these people
to be now who worship at the altar of
gaia if you were to say well how far
does it go like china's one child policy
they would have said oh okay straw man
red herring and rightfully i would think
many of them would have agreed with it
in in their heart of hearts it's like
yeah you know god damn well there's too
many people on this planet it's like
they have to go somewhere or other where
a cancer on the surface of the planet
well i guess i gave him the benefit of
the doubt and then hearing ted turner
say it and i thought that's as extreme
as it gets
and that's not a problem
okay i'm out i'm out with any i'm not on
board with any i'm not going to feign
being a centrist here because this guy
wants to okay so why did you think that
was a bad idea so like why not why not
have fewer people and and why wouldn't
that be better for the planet what do
you see as a danger in that well that
comes from a fundamental worldview where
i don't believe that uh that basically
our role here is to uh be subservient to
the planet our role here is to go forth
and subdue the planet and that we were
created in the image of god and not not
the wildebeest not the beasts of the
field nor the fish of the sea i think we
need to be good stewards of the planet
but the minute you start getting into
the territory of eliminating human life
for the betterment of the planet to me
that's
a pagan religion diametrically opposed
to not only uh obviously the christian
worldview um but a pro-human worldview i
just don't think you can do it
you're killing babies right you can't
tell you walk who's gonna
we talk about taxes
who's gonna enforce hey on a second is
that your is that child number two i
mean we know what happens in china i've
made jokes about them yeah that's that
that's that's that's the that's the uh
that's more that's a straightforward
route to walk down it's like yeah you
really want to see that much power to
your governmental structure right and
you're not worried about
authoritarianism are you sure of that
and are you so sure that your motives
for positing that have nothing to do
with anything but your saint-like
devotion to the long-term
well-being of the entire planet
you're really sure of that are you and
and why and how come you're not sure
that maybe you're
not a bit bitter and maybe you just
don't like people that much because life
is hard and you've suffered a lot and
you're angry and this is a bit of
revenge and like if you don't think you
have motivations like that then i don't
think you've thought very much because
if you put someone in the vice press and
make them suffer they're going to
produce all sorts of bitter ideas
and so
we have to watch out for that we have to
be very careful about that so well i
think that's an interesting parallel
right the climate situation because i've
always said this i'm not look i'm not
saying that there is no impact of course
in humans and climate change and i'm not
i'm not a climb i'm not a scientist i
don't work for noah even though they get
their predictions wrong every single
year but my point is i don't hold myself
out to be an expert however
i can i can say it doesn't pass a sniff
test when i read the entire 16 page
green new deal and it says
and social uh justice and
social justice and equity in there i'm
like well hold on a second you just you
just added everything into this bill
this doesn't make sense right i don't
have to say hey uh hear my scienti or
present my scientific qualifications to
say i don't believe that aoc or the u.n
have a shot in fixing it and getting
china to play in line when you look at
the policy proposals
way way down the trails policy proposals
no way they work so it doesn't matter if
your science leads to those policy
proposals you can't enact it
so let's try and be better and not throw
our [ __ ] out the window you know when
we're working you have to be a pretty
damn cautious scientist to posit that
the science
um necessarily elicits a given policy
approach because
one of the things you learn as a
practicing scientist is that you set up
your experiment to test the micro
details of your pet theory and
it's highly probable that the
experimental results will turn out some
other way than you predict it even when
you're trying to predict small things
and so to say we could go from the
science to the policy as if there's no
intervening mystery and as if as a
scientist you're 100 certain that the
imposition of your policy is only going
to produce the results you intended and
nothing else none of that science right
a scientist with any sense would never
ever make a claim like that having
learned through painful laboratory
experience that everything will go wrong
with your stupid theory that you can
possibly imagine and then a whole bunch
more too
so there isn't a direct line from the
science to the policy it's it when
anyone ever tells you that
they're not speaking as a scientist
except perhaps in you know
extraordinarily limited cases that
moving from
what the situation is to what we should
do about it to bring a given future into
being that's that's an unbelievably
difficult proposition and
science can only solve that in micro
in in micro domains and so that's the
problem with saying well you know the
science is settled it's like yeah
why are you telling me that like why is
it so important for you
that i believe that oh well it's because
i need to do these things it's like yeah
that's exactly why right because the
science just sits there as a set of
facts i said in some sense if it's
properly done as a set of disembodied
facts right well what do we do about
that well that's a different question
how do we decide what to do about it
that's a different question too
those aren't scientific questions as far
as i can tell i know
i think we almost see sort of the art
world mirrored in science a little bit
and this goes right to sort of sort of
what you're talking about and how this
is happening in real time if you want to
know what will happen with the climate
proposals long term
take a long-term version of what's been
accelerated with covid and the radical
changes in proposals because we didn't
take that first step at least not in a
multitude of ways going okay where are
we what is actually happening we rushed
to you have to do this this is what has
to be done this has to be the proposal
wait hold on a second put that back
we're going to change it and as a
comedian i've talked about this with
with comedy i think there's
the objective right objectively funny
you put people there maybe people don't
find them but like richard pryor george
carlin nor macdonald right you may not
love them but they're objectively funny
objectively unfunny which is people
who've been open miking for 20 years and
never made a dime they're obviously not
very good and then they're subjective
this is with most art right some art
will appeal to some people i think with
science there is the objective facts
data at some point something is settled
otherwise we never get anything done for
example if i say the room temperature is
67 degrees right now i know that it is
otherwise someone will be fired if it's
not i'm a tyrant now there's the uh
objectively incorrect i know the room is
not 63 degrees because i can look at the
thermometer but then there's the
subjective of how do we most effectively
let's say get 267 degrees and it seems
as though we've really just blurred that
line
in covid with the objective and that
whole subjective or in science yet to be
determined and we've altered everyone's
lives because of it and that's not to
say that it's not a pandemic and that
it's not a virus that is particularly
lethal to certain groups of people
um
but it seems like a lot right now
especially in big tech asking the why
we've done what we've done and if this
this is the correct course forward it's
really scary and a lot of people are
afraid to speak out this is something
you and i haven't had a chance to talk
about because i've spoken in a while
the world has changed dramatically has
it changed your view of where the world
is going fundamentally than when we last
spoke maybe a year and a half two years
ago
well i i have been shocked
to see how
fragile our civil liberties have turned
out to be
across the west i mean we basically
china put the first lockdowns into place
and we mimic so we mimic the actions of
a totalitarian state instantly
now you know what we didn't know what to
do exactly in some sense so i it's a
complicated problem we didn't know the
magnitude of the problem
um
and it's hard to criticize people
in some sense for
jumping to
conclusions prematurely
right but
but
it's
a long while later
and
the danger of using danger as an excuse
for social control
is making itself more and more manifest
yeah
so i've been very very sick through most
of this so i haven't had a chance to
think it through as much as i might have
wanted to and i've been criticized for
that too for you know not adding my
voice to the general clamor i mean
i i spoke again with
well leader of a new political party in
canada maxine bernier after i spoke with
john anderson about about the covet
issue my sense is that with the proper
policy move essentially i think is
something like
well we've got the vaccines
we think they're useful
you can get one whenever you want
now and so and lots of people have got
them
so january 15th
everything's open and if you don't if
you're not vaccinated and you have your
reasons for that
well then we'll still do what we can to
make sure the systems are in place to
take care of you if you get sick but
it's time to get back to normal and i
think an approach like that would
actually convince a lot more people to
get vaccinated because
when you push and you push and you force
and you mandate
then
all you do is increase the skepticism
radically increase the skepticism of
those who are skeptical of pushing and
forcing and shoving and mandating right
and
i just see that i see all of that
mandate all of that force as a admission
of the failure of policy
yeah like why you didn't convince you
didn't convince as many people as you
think you should have that the vaccine
was a good idea well whose fault is that
well it's the anti-vaxxers those sons of
[ __ ] no no no you
didn't formulate your argument properly
you didn't formulate your argument
carefully it's not so clear that all
those idiots
it's their problem and they're just
stupid and malevolent compared to you
it's a policy failure and you don't
admit that you won't admit that and so
now you think you're justified in the
use of of force
and so but and you're justifying that
because well you're you're doing the
right thing
it's like are you are you doing the
right thing exactly i remember one of
the vaccinations so sure
first came out it was unanimous right
the the insult du jour was oh you d you
dumb uh you dumb uh anti-vaxxers okay
republicans will kill off their own base
problem solved right darwin awards i
thought great
if you believe that then
let him win it and then it became this
is a pandemic of the unvaccinated you
said you didn't care let them kill
themselves off that is proof positive
that the argument they presented was
that someone not being vaccinated didn't
affect them and i don't even want to get
into the whole man anyway people know
where i line up on that but i will say
this well you see weird you see very
weird things happening in australia
right now and so for example there and i
hope i've got this right but
the police there using an app
that
works on your cell phone which so
conveniently happens to know where you
are
which perhaps turns out to not be such a
good thing and maybe you have to send
the police a photograph of yourself
with something in the background that
proves you are in fact right there it's
like okay are you so sure that that app
isn't more dangerous than the virus
right
you know because it's not obvious like
these you look at an app like you look
at this technology this technology is
stunningly
cataclysmically powerful right and you
think well it's just an app it's like
yeah and tinder was just a dating app
too but it completely transformed the
psychological dynamics of human sexual
interactions now whether that's how
permanent that is is a whole different
question but we're faced with these
radical technologies every day and we
don't even notice how revolutionary they
are like this app this is this is quite
something that you have to send that the
technology is already there to establish
a system that makes it the case that you
have to take a photograph of yourself
and send it to the police so they know
where you are so that you can go and do
your business
are you sure that's not more dangerous
than the virus
yeah and because it isn't obvious to me
no it's not ibis and i would take that
one step back you know because i was
accused of being a conspiracy theorist
when i said uh red lights uh red light
cameras are unconstitutional same exact
argument because light camera can't it's
not a human being it doesn't present
context these things can be faulty and
you don't have the right to monitor me
at any point in any intersection so
worse than that worse than that are you
so sure that establishing the precedent
that enables a machine
to find someone and elicit the force of
the state is a good precedent right
because remember these things are
getting twice as smart every
year or so
it's like where exactly do we want them
to go well if nature's kind that
australian app technology will uh be
relegated to yet another pile of uh a
mechanism for dick pics
yeah well we'll see greatest hope we'll
see won't we it's terrifying to think of
and i would say this what scared me most
is not just policy
not that um i've always believed that
civil rights certainly the government
would see them as
brittle
what struck me the most and i and then
we'll go to we'll go to uh mug club only
a little bit uh here because we've been
going along on youtube and i want to
show a clip of you sort of talking about
authoritarian regimes and their relation
with infectious diseases uh which may be
a little little difficult on youtube we
never know what they what they'll think
about that but i will say this what's
scared me the most
and as someone who's far more thoughtful
than myself i'd love to hear your
thoughts what scared me more is not what
the government would do i never realized
how willing half of the country half of
the world and now even more but my
fellow countrymen
are willing to rat me out
even knowing that it could come with
dire violent consequences we're going i
i want to flag this person look this
person's breaking the rule this person
can't be allowed to go in public this
person doesn't have a passport and revel
in it yeah what you also want to ask
yourself is are you so sure you want to
set up policy that rewards that kind of
behavior right because you think well
it's for a good reason it's like yeah
well
you train
people do what they practice
and they practice what you incentivize
uh you sure you want to incentivize that
and so i mean we have these liberties
in some sense to distribute
decision-making power so that
cataclysmic errors aren't made in the
name of doing the best thing right
so
but did you so i think well i think the
vaccines are there i'm vaccinated for
what it's worth and i'm not stating that
as some badge of moral superiority
but i'm still
i it seems to me that
the right policy move is here's the
vaccines
they're available we're opening up take
your chances and away we go yeah and
let's get back to our our free life
now the problem is what's scary is the
fact that you just said something
entirely reasonable and i go yeah that
sounds and i don't even necessarily know
that i agree i think that i would take
it more extreme you know being the
right-wing extremist i would say they
had no authority to do any of this in
the first place and take it a step
further but the point is
either one of our views
could result in this being removed
because the policies
and this goes to the first amendment
right it doesn't just involve the
government now now you have people who
meet with the federal government who
meet with international governing bodies
i mean it's not again it's not a
conspiracy to say mark zuckerberg susan
wojcicki jack dorsett these people are
in a meeting a closed room meeting and
come out with agreed upon terms of what
you're allowed to say
look behind us there's the orwellian
double double think and
i will say that has accelerated
exponentially
um since the last time we've we've
spoken and it it it is scary that's what
scares me not a new disease or even the
next pandemic what scares me more is my
fellow countrymen
well the next the next pandemic worries
me too because we've now we've
established a precedent which is that's
true if the health uh
risk is severe enough
then your civil liberties are optional
okay so
well exactly how severe
i mean exactly
and then then i think about other
freedoms that we have like the freedom
to drive
that's actually pretty dangerous
and it's not that good for the planet
and so just what makes you think that
you should be doing that
exactly
like the safety issue
the impact issue
it's very it's very disturbing to me to
see
those issues being hijacked for
what are essentially political purposes
yeah and it's worrisome remember that
shocking moment when you first get
behind the wheel of the car by yourself
when you're 16 or 17 on your
what two tons of steel glass and
gasoline and i can point it
anywhere no kidding
it's no kidding there's nothing there's
nothing that embodies individual freedom
more than
uh 550 horsepower
internal combustion engine sports car in
the hands of a young man well now you're
just shooting
yeah i had to fight the old ford
windstar
it's bloody amazing that that ever
that that was ever allowed i know i know
it is absolutely and you know what the
same thing can be said for the first
time i ever shot a gun when i moved to
the united states i said oh oh
oh this is the finality this isn't a
film and that's why i've always
encouraged people to take proper
shooting lessons and just go understand
what it is to respect the power of
anything mechanical um whether it be a
an automobile or be a be a a gun um and
with our kids too i will have my kids
shooting very very young just to make
sure they respect it because i tell you
what i knew i think i was 20 years old
when i first fired a firearm i said you
know what had i never shot a gun
i don't know that if i walked into the
magical closet of mystery and stumbled
across a gun let's say a friend's
father's gun that i would have respected
it but i know if i would have shot this
gun when i was a kid i absolutely would
have and so i spoke with my wife i said
we're going to get them to a shooting
range with us supervised as young as
they can so that they learn respect for
it because i had no respect
at all for that and very little respect
for my parents paneled winstar
it was an awful awful awful vehicle you
couldn't get a less cool car actually no
wait
that was the upgrade it was an old
aerostar which was shittier okay we're
going to go to
mug club because i want to show a clip
talking about authoritarian regimes and
infectious diseases but the book the new
one if people don't have it as i say new
because you've been here in a while
beyond order 12 more rules for life
there might be some bonus rules in there
because he likes them where can people
get it there uh professor
they can get it anywhere
any bookstore any bookseller online at
amazon it's
it's around and so if you like the first
book well hopefully you like the second
book uh the online consensus seems to be
on amazon there's thousands of reviews
that it's an improvement over the first
book so i hope that's true
well
you tease me as the professor knows i
can't read uh youtube thank you very
much we're going to go discuss things
that you may not allow we don't know not
going to chance at piss off
[Music]